pierre perret j'étais la pièce à côté
j'ai entendu rire tout d'un coup que
vous leur avez raconté que c'était 3 à
je racontais un épisode d'une visite
chez lui qui était au départ je suis
arrivé j'ai frappé j'ai alors la porte
était entrouverte chercheur entré comme
je faisais souvent il était dans un
petit coin avec une assiette y avait une
espèce de purée brune dans son assiette
qui touille avec une petite cuillère et
tous les chats étaient autour et que je
dis bonjour monsieur léautaud
vous êtes en train de faire la pâte et
des chars sinon c'est la vielle alors il
le hibou des il s'est mis à bouder et
moi j'avais pas tellement l'habitude
haye s'est assis dans un fauteuil il
avait l'habitude quand il vous est il
tournait le dos alors ostensiblement on
était face à face dans un fauteuil comme
ça mais il me tournait le dos et alors
moi je savais pas quoi faire on sait
qu'elle adore j'avais une pipe jeu
bourré ma pipe je lâche tu regardais
l'émission jusqu'au moment où tout d'un
coup il me lancer une phrase comme ça
alors j'ai pas pu venir avant où il
éprouvait le besoin de deux de m'offrir
de me faire cadeau de trucs chaque fois
que j'allais chez lui il roulait
toujours ses cigarettes ou savez je ne
mets pas les tout cousu comme on appelle
un cas isolé dans ses doigts
alors il m'offrait des paquets de
gauloises
on lui offrait des gones oil pareil les
fumées paris l'a28 royrie l'aller ils
enregistrent chaque fois il prenait
d'autres paquets de gauloises hymne des
données et puis des bouquins aussi de
temps en temps je rêvais offert les plus
belles pages de stendhal dont il avait
préfacé le volume l'un est d'ailleurs je
j'ai pas ouvert pendant trois ou quatre
ans mais tandis que j'avais les ouvrages
de stendhal mais ça m'avait fait grand
plaisir un jour j'ai feuilleté
le bouquin et j'ai trouvé deux dans une
page de journal manuscrit des années
1923 qui était resté dedans qui vont
avoir enfin c'était avec un passage même
un petit peu croustillantes pourrais pas
dire ici il aimait bien stands alors oui
mais surtout la correspondance j'ai
acheté pour 12 par ipsen
une idée originale cependant ça a été
une révélation pour complice que l'arm
et aujourd'hui encore chaque fois que je
rencontre on les appelait qu'elle
rachetait le de leurs hameaux et
quartiers y croit la com du ce pas la
peine de les ados je connais vous priver
quelqu'un de mal aujourd'hui
ça tombe pas dans de mauvaises mains
mais la rencontre et avait connu il
avait déjà 3 81 quelques années et il ne
travaillait plus il avait 83 ans et les
gens se retourner sur lui dans la rue
raoul ouvrir une fois sur le boulevard
saint germain avec sa canne il a tapé
sur un un photographe de rue qui
voulaient nous prendre d'ailleurs je
regrette bien mais j'aurais au moins une
photo avec ses îles et s'est approché il
ya tapé dessus des fichiers oil corp
laissez-moi troc
il s'appellera une et où es tu étais mon
coca sylvain chapeau de tweets comme une
espèce de pot de chambre à l'envers et
on s'était vraiment au quartier latin
alors maintenant il faudrait connaître
l'origine de cette passion pour les
autos parce que elle vous est venue très
vite
moi ça m'est venue j'étais étudiant au
conservatoire à l'époque et j'avais
des lectures vraiment assez particulière
pour un pour un jeune de 17 ans 18 ans
j'avais lu avait pas que les entretiens
qu'il avait avec ma les riques robert
malley et ça m'avait vraiment accroché
au possible
j'étais fasciné par ce personnage et je
m'étais promis un montant à paris parce
que tout ça se passait à toulouse vous
ai promis que quand je montre appareils
iphone disait de connaître les autos
parce que je m'imaginais naïvement qu il
fallait que je connaisse lui aussi sur
la jeanne d'arc
et puis vraiment je suis arrivé à paris
j'ai ressources et pris le train en gare
du luxembourg là j'ai débarqué à
fontenay aux roses
j'ai été frappé chez les autres et puis
vraiment au moment où j'ai frappé chez
lui je me suis dit mais j'ai ya eu la
minute de vérité a ajouté me tuer tu
fout quoi ces jeunes a rien à faire
c'est ce que ce personnage c'est très
déplacé ce que tu fais là enfin j'ai
vraiment eu un sursaut de pudeur je me
suis dit il a ouvert la porte
j'ai vu un personnage devant moi avec
des yeux effarés qui m'a regardé puis
très très désagréable mais qu'est ce que
vous voulez et puis là alors j'ai
vraiment fait le bois en un millième de
seconde derrière
je dis rien et puis il a haussé les
épaules et matelas qui appartenait j'ai
repris l'escalier et puis la porte j'ai
réouvert
il m'a rattrapée dans l'escalier
m'alimenter monter plus vite nom de dieu
vous allez laisser partir mais cher je
suis monté à tout berzingue série il
était une heure et demie de l'après midi
à peu près et j'ai quitté les eaux tour
le soir vers 8h30 9h c'est lui qui m'a
raccompagné un jardin il y avait de la
boue et où il m'a dit vous allez vous
casser le cou attendait jours
accompagnés écrit de lampes électriques
et tout mais là qu'est ce que vous êtes
dit prenant cette première journée
commence que la conversation a commencé
d'abord il a voulu savoir qui j'étais
qu'est ce que je faisais et quand je lui
ai dit je suis comédien alors il a été
transfiguré
mais ça a été
des questions en pagaille qui ont fusé
même qu'est ce que vous jouez avec votre
physique vous devez jouer les vallées de
comédie il s'agit exactement jouer
mascaret enfin tout répertoire de
molière
il m'a expliqué il m'a parlé pendant 1 à
2 heures du misanthrope du personnage et
c'est pour pour savoir si je m'étais
bien imprégné j'ai effectivement il m'a
appris à me milliers de choses quoi il
m'a lu des poèmes et fort je vous dis ça
a duré un temps fou il a été vraiment
très mais ces frappes qui vous ai cités
misanthrope parce qu'en fait ils
devaient se reconnaître dans alceste
mais bien sûr ça tout le monde y mena
fédération long de sa vie et justement
je pense que s'il en a parlé avec autant
de brio c'est parce qu'il connaît bien
la question exactement
alors qu'est ce qu'il vous a conseillé
de lire par exemple du lot il ya déjà
une chose au départ qu'il avait fait
éclater de rire c'est que comme j'avais
vraiment là la bouche pas le conflit
mort même si je sais que c'était
vraiment la dernière chose à faire ici
on était idiot de ma part de courte
portée les autos mais et même enfin bon
sang qu'est ce que vous trouvez de 2
qu'est ce qui vous attire pourquoi vous
venez j'ai dis parce que j'ai lu propos
d'un jour j'ai vu les entretiens avec
malev ont une vie alors j'ai trouvé ça
extraordinaire mais ma vie
extraordinaire venez vous n'avez jamais
rien lu et j'ai dit non clac debré et
puis il m'a dit bon qu'est ce que vous
faites
qu'est ce que vous faites demain et le
lendemain moi je rentrais à l'armée je
rentrais au service militaire je dis
rien je dis tant pis je rentre pas ils
savaient que je suis rentré en retard le
lendemain j'ai été avec les autos qui
est venu au luxembourg il m'a emmené on
a fait une quinzaine de libraires dans
l'après midi et on a acheté alors enfin
il m'a fait acheter une foule de
bouquins lautréamont voltaire stendhal
la correspondance
je ne sais pas je suis parti avec des
piles de bouquins comme ça on est arrivé
par exemple chez un écrivain chez un
libraire pardon est alors dès qu'il a vu
les libraires étaient vraiment assez sur
leurs petits souliers
et alors et d'énumérer les autos qu'est
ce que je voudrais originaux et beaux
esprits de l'angleterre contemporaine
monsieur qui s'appelle sacré un
humoriste anglais et dure nous allons
voir je ne sais pas si vous en avez des
caisses dans la cave du bien bien je
retrouve là il est parti il est revenue
couvert de poussière et du effectivement
voilà en deux volumes montrez moi ça va
secouer sa sueur s'appelle reid une
poussière intérim et du bon ben voilà ça
va très bien aidé
comme je vous dois alors aidez vous
savez c'est pour un des ses pour un
petit militaire qui est assez démunis il
faudrait lui faire un point tu veux
écouter ça fera à 600 francs et les
autobus combien de 400 pour enlever
toute l'après-midi comme ça il marchant
dans les bouquins comme un chiffonnier
je suis reparti avec une pile de
bouquins dans les deux bras
heureux comme tout et je vais payer ça
deux ou trois mille france qu à l'époque
et j'ai fait un timide la période de mai
de mes grandes lectures comme parce que
vraiment je puis je me faisais tout
expliquer par la suite on parlait de des
passages je crois que ça l'amusé avant
tout parce que je ne vois pas je ne vois
pas tellement l'intérêt que les autos
pouvait avoir à connaître ce personnage
comme nous
[Musique]